so now you have to remember the context
of this over 40 5 000 Small Boat
Crossings last year and the Prime
Minister has made this one of his five
pledges now he's a prime minister that
doesn't like to promise what he can't
deliver uh you might remember back at
the G7 in Japan he refused to commit to
previous conservative Manifesto targets
of getting legal net migration down
below a quarter of a million that was a
2019 pledge it's at record levels of 606
000 uh currently so he wouldn't commit
to reducing legal net migration back to
previous pledges but what about the stop
the boats pledge because it seems that
perhaps this is a pledge that he too
cannot deliver that has definitely been
a lot of skepticism around it well he
was here today to say look my plan is
working Boat Crossings at this time of
the year compared to a year ago he said
were down by a fifth he was asked
whether that was to do with weather
conditions rather than his policies he
said well the evidence shows that they
are up across other parts of Europe so
therefore he thinks the plan is working
I guess the big question is that when he
says stop the boats can he really in
2019 boat Crossing stood at about 1800
in 2020 it was about eight and a half
thousand in 2021 it was 28 and a half
thousand we haven't had any commitment
from the Prime Minister about what
numbers he actually wants to get to when
he was asked in the press conference he
didn't answer that question he swerved
it